are you optimistic or pessimistic about
the future I'm incredibly optimistic uh
okay the way it's gone at the moment I
would like to be optimistic but a little
bit pessimistic what I see scares me and
fills me with dread a CNN poll earlier
this year found that a majority of
Americans are pessimistic about the
future of the country that's consistent
with earlier polling which discovered
that more people than not believe that
the next generation will be worse off
than they are we ventured out to the
Venice Boardwalk to ask people from all
walks of life how they feel about the
future and maybe it was the pleasant
beachside atmosphere or the fact that
they were on camera but most people
actually told us that they do feel the
sense of optimism I feel truly
optimistic about the future I am
optimistic I'm optimistic about
everything they get up to mix with
everything the world you know but
everything turns out for the good but it
only took a little digging into the
issues to uncover the seeds of pessimism
with all the war and all that stuff will
not I'm not sure I'm a realist and I
know that there are things that are
going in in the world that are very very
serious and in our questioning one
recurring character popped up again and
again I'm the biggest fan of Donald
Trump at the moment Donald Trump
everybody hating Trump I assume you're
talking about Donald Trump yeah we tried
to cheer them up with some statistics
that should give even the most hardened
cynic some hope for a better future like
in Brazil the Amazon forests and the old
ring photos over there a quarter of it
was already cut do you think that there
are more or less forests than there were
you know 20 or 30 years ago it's less
he's wrong about that scientist is
called the turnaround in the world's
forests the great reversal and a study
out of the University of Hull insky
found that the forests in the majority
of countries have been thickening for
the past two or three decades part of
this reversal is thanks to an even more
remarkable trend thanks to advances in
biotech and agriculture the amount of
land ploughed by farmers increased by
only about 10 percent while we've grown
tripled the amount of food if crop
yields had been stuck in 1960s levels we
would have needed to farm an area almost
twice the size of South America to feed
the Dowling population in
instead the efficiencies in farming have
encouraged urbanization rural
populations will be nearly cut in half
by 2050 according to UN projections
potentially returning huge plots of land
to nature
researchers at Rockefeller University
say we might be on the verge of peak
farmland meaning an area twice the size
of France could be restored to nature by
2060 it's good to know that the problems
is being worse and now we're in better
position to see the future do you think
the world is a more or less dangerous
place than it used to be I think it is a
more dangerous world about violence like
do you think gun violence is better or
worse than it was 20 years ago
fortunately worse actually it's better
better better maybe cuz I think of those
big chaotic events not only has the FBI
documented just about every metric of
violence on a downward trend since the
mid 1990s gun violence was cut in half
despite a doubling of gun sales and
violence worldwide has been declining
since well almost forever battle deaths
from war are on a constant decline and
while the atrocities of groups like Isis
and politicians like Syria's Bashar
al-assad are real and truly horrifying
those tragic death tolls are still
dwarfed in comparison to the mass murder
and genocide routinely carried out by
heads of state in the mid 20th century
under the banners of communism and
fascism and while the threat of
terrorism still looms large in the minds
of many Americans a civilian on US soil
is about four times more likely to be
struck by lightning than killed in a
terrorist attack but fear of violence
persists in this country possibly
because of breathless media coverage of
terrorism and mass shootings that fails
to put the magnitude of the problem in
proper context think about the next
generation do you think they'll have it
better or worse than we do
I think worse as far as economy and all
that things are becoming more or less
affordable not becoming very affordable
starting with food unemployment may be
back to around 5% but that's partly
because many Americans have dropped out
of the labor market altogether so it's
no surprise that they're pessimistic
about
economy but there's still reason for
optimism in this realm if historical
trends hold if you break the income of
Americans into quintiles and think of
them as rungs on the economic ladder one
study of US Treasury data found that 95
percent of families on the lowest rung
moved up at least one wrong in their
lifetime with a majority actually moving
to the top two rungs and 82 percent of
kids whose parents were on the bottom
rung moved up at least one rung not only
that but the bang for your buck is
increasing the amount of hours the
poorest Americans have to work to afford
household appliances and luxury items
has steadily declined since the 1950s
like back in the 50s you get to work
four times as many hours just to buy a
refrigerator as today that's very very
exciting I do see there are generation
we do work glass we work less we're a
little get a little more out of it more
yes we make the most of our time what if
I told you that among even the poorest
Americans over the last 40 years there's
been a 28% increase in purchasing power
that is uplifting I mean that does help
it's you know better for the people now
let's move back to the big loud orange
elephant in the room for a moment a big
beautiful powerful wall when I see
politicians stand in front of people and
make fun of others and say horrible
things and then I see increased racism
that bothers me a lot when people talk
negatively against minorities when
people talk about walls going up that's
very very dangerous regardless of your
feelings about Donald Trump or any other
political leader people on all sides of
the spectrum should be optimistic about
the future of human freedom and the
decline of authoritarianism around the
globe governments everywhere are moving
away from autocratic dictators and
towards democratically elected
representatives the majority of
countries are now democracies and that
was not always the case in other words
democracy is winning does that make you
feel any better
democracy is the way to go but I will
say I don't really believe that
government's changed the world I believe
people changed the world and that's up
to you and me
despite frustrating government policies
and unlikable politicians many of the
people we spoke to were optimistic about
the freedom that technology gives us our
increasingly tolerant society and the
ever-increasing level of choice in their
own lives I think we're just on the edge
of a next electric car electric
everything revolution the technology can
save us like as the species you just
know whatever you want get the answer in
an instant pretty much so yeah
technology does solve some and most
problems there's also great
opportunities with these new app based
work where you can work for yourself
example for lyft that's pretty amazing
sauce OC growth there have we made you
feel any more optimistic today yeah
definitely we made you any more
optimistic today yeah yeah I mean just
the fact that we're interested and
people are interested in you know
learning about it and keeping their eye
on it it's good to know the stats are
getting better thank you for telling me
there's more pessimists in the world
because I'm optimistic and while they're
sitting eating a half gallon of ice
cream watching Netflix at high stream
I'll be out making money doing something
fun what do you say to the pessimists
lighten up
you